first of all let me start by saying
congratulations on the movie it is so
well done we've been talking for years
and every time I spoke to you over the
years I would always talk about Bohemian
Rhapsody in the Queen movie and I know
up what kind of journey this has been
for you so what this is ten years what
is it like to finally have this movie
coming out in like a few days
nerve-wracking
absolutely nerve-wracking because this
is what we do you know you spend a
decade developing screenplays and
casting filming post-production the real
guys involved and it comes down to will
people go and see it will we find an
audience it seems like we will the buzz
is pretty good but I don't put my heart
and soul into that and just wait and
wait to see what happens
sure there are many versions of the
Queen story that you could sort of put
on screen there's so many backstories to
each album to who they are as people
how challenging was to find this version
the one you ended up putting on screen
along the way it was eight and a half
years worth of work with writers and
ideas and coming up with different
scenes and coming up with where we're
gonna put music and how we gonna tell
Freddy story whether it's he's he's
music career story his personal story
his sexuality and it was just finding
that balance and then finding the cast
to all blend in with that so it was one
of the toughest that I've ever taken on
and when you've got Brian May and Roger
Taylor and Miami Beach which I'm gonna
call him now because most people won't
know what that means soon I'm sure
you know kind of in one way helping you
in another way saying well it wasn't
quite like that you know you have to
balance all that and then you got a
Studios voice come in later on and say
well you should do this and do that it
was it was extremely difficult but I
think we got it right I'm not sure ya
know so the film is really really well
done I'm curious how close did you come
to making another version of the Queen
story with maybe a different filmmaker
or because I know Sasha was involved for
a little bit in a bun
there's been rumors of all these other
people did any ever come close to going
no well there was one version we hadn't
cast yet but in fact it was tester
Dexter and I were like in early days of
prepping the film around five years ago
but I I woke up one morning we read the
script and said you know what this isn't
ready yet this is a mistake and there
were things that I just wasn't
comfortable with in the story and so for
me you got one shot at this you better
get it right and I remember just walking
in one day and just shutting the movie
down and saying I'm not comfortable with
the storytelling so we're just gonna
move hot and a lot of people got very
upset and a lot of press we're talking
about Dexter and I'm not getting along
and I fired him I didn't fire him
it was about I wasn't happy with the
script and I promised for I am Roger
Taylor Jim Beach until I'm really
satisfied with it I'm not gonna make
this film and I feel as a producer when
you take on real people's life stories I
feel that burden and so I wanted to get
it right and I remember the first
screening of this version of the only
version actually with Brian and Roger I
just watched my may watch the film I
didn't take my eyes off him and it was
most nerve-wracking experience I've ever
gone through on a Sunday morning not far
from here and he got up afterwards and
he was in tears and he said I absolutely
loved it and I actually thought my job
was done sure this is one of those rare
movies that if I if you had said to me
you can see a five hour version I would
have said yes please
so I I would I absolutely would see a
longer version how long since you
obviously were involved in the Edit how
long was your first cut was there ever a
version that was a lot longer than this
the first cut was a little bit longer I
won't say a lot longer we had the full
live aid set because they did the full
live headset you know we were lucky you
and crazy little things involved and we
use those songs in the film so we didn't
want to repeat them and have them on
stage there wasn't that much other than
within the body of the film that we cut
out
so for me you know this was the script
and the script was very tight and I just
feel that we told the story in the in
the Edit room that we needed to tell in
John Hoffman our editor who was
absolutely phenomenal putting that
montage together over fat bottomed girls
and the way he created that was was just
so amazingly entertaining for an
audience that we basically kept the film
sure I am a huge queen fan so every bit
of deleted scenes I would see will will
I see them playing 39 in Japan will I
see a crazy little thing called love in
the bathtub with Rami stuff like that if
I knew anything about the movie you may
you may but come over one day and I'll
show you everything just bring that
tequila and we'll we'll run it all night
sir you haven't that's not a problem I
will I'm gonna hold you to that to find
Tommy I love the live aid stuff it is
filled with this amazing energy and you
almost want to sing along in the theater
can you talk about getting filming that
sequence and the challenges of
recreating this iconic set well it was
it was daunting and especially there was
the first week of shooting or first ten
days of shooting and when the actors saw
the schedule they who came to me in the
vision said what are you kidding me
you're throwing us into live aids but it
really works out well because they all
came together and bonded at that moment
and for me I've never been emotional
about any movie I've ever done and I
stood on that Live Aid set and was
basically in tears watching them do the
rehearsal because I saw and saw through
the process that the work that they put
into it and let's face it they made the
live aid work right and then
intercutting with an audience ambient
being at a point where obviously
Wembley's not Wembley anymore so we had
to CGI a lot of the crowd was a big
advantage for us because we could create
that storytelling with the band and
Freddie and the audience and so we had
those luxury tools with us to do that
but basically the four guys that played
these guys created that moment and it
was
something I'd never seen before when we
finished shooting the last day alive 8 I
say if we can get the rest of the movie
even this much close to what we just did
we're gonna have a success
Rahmi is amazing as Freddy just a
literal transformation when did you
first realize or first know he's gonna
nail this
I could be really presumptuous to say in
my office what not afternoon but it was
really actually just before Live Aid
started before we started shooting I was
with him we were doing costume fittings
for him and he was being Freddie in an
office not far from here and I was
videotaping him on my iPhone you know
just to kind of go back and watch later
and I was so confident that he was gonna
be Freddie after that after seeing that
and the work that he put in was
extraordinary even behind the scenes as
a producer you kind of are see actors
kind of like to get into their roles
build a chemistry bond together and have
Lee acts has become the roles that
they're playing and with him I didn't
have to say anything he just did it and
you can see that on the screen and there
was so much talk about other actors
before
I'm prior to and different version of
the screenplays and all of that was just
talk that was never the case and I had
never cast a Freddie I never had someone
sign a deal saying they're gonna be
Freddie Mercury until Remy walked in
it's my office one day and I just saw
something in him the DNA of who he was
in that room that day was become was
Freddie Mercury and I was so confident
that I remember going out to the studio
and saying this is who's gonna be
Freddie Mercury that's it sure one of
the things is Mary and Freddie's
relationship in real life was very
unique and very like ahead of the curve
if you will in terms of talk a little
bit about putting capturing the honesty
of that relationship putting it on
screen and trying to make sure it was
there I was complicated because we knew
that a lot of people didn't know that
freddie was engaged to Mary Austin in
fact a lot of people didn't know there
was a Mary Austin in his life so is very
complicated to get that right and I
think
I'm accountant and I used to spend hours
in a room discussing that relationship
and discussing how it can affect a
modern-day audience so it can't feel
old-fashioned it had to feel modern-day
and because freddie was ahead of his
time and mary was as well in a certain
extent if you look at the scene where he
goes to Bieber and he he's looking at
clothes and said this is a women's
section then it to me that was the
moment the pivotal moment where she got
who he was and she saw that and again I
think that plays into an audience of
today's world rather than in the 1970s
completely I got to stop there I mean it
sincerely you did a great job thank you
so much it's gonna be bigger thank you
so much
you